[Musique]
nous sommes le 12 janvier 2017 bonsoir
et bienvenue pour cette émission dédiée
à celles et ceux qui font l'actualité
dans le département des yvelines et
voici l les titres en images vous
entendrez et dans quelques instants
jean-loup charron le président de la
fédération française de golf en début de
semaine un partenariat a été signé avec
le groupe chinois à chaîne à la dotation
de l'open de france à saint quentin en
yvelines explose quelles conséquences
pour la discipline sur notre territoire
et puis après pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental hier c'est au tour
de patrick devedjian son homologue dans
les hauts-de-seine de nous livrer son
regard sur la fusion en cours entre les
deux entités
ses attentes ses ambitions au cours de
cette édition du 7 8 les invités c'est
enfin signé après plusieurs mois de
tractations le groupe chinois a h1n1 va
donc sponsorisés à l'open de france à
saint quentin en yvelines ce partenariat
va permettre au tournoi implanté plus
précisément à guyancourt d'augmenter sa
dotation à part 3 cette dotation est
maintenant de près de 6 millions d'euros
de même plus de six millions d'euros est
des stars mondiales du golfe devrait
donc se presser sur à les greens de 50
ans dès l'été prochain elle nicolas
kirillovitch a pu recueillir la réaction
du président de la fédération française
de golf jean-loup un charron qui a reçu
d'ailleurs récemment est la médaille
d'honneur de la ville de guyancourt
monsieur charon vous avez parlé pendant
cette conférence de presse de nouvelles
et dimensions pour l'open de golf avec
ce nouveau partenariat expliqué nous un
peu plus précisément pourquoi l'open de
golf on rentre dans une nouvelle
dimension désormais oui un plaisir
puisque l'arrivée dash henin à l'open de
france entend partenaire titre signifie
également une mise de fonds plus
importante qu'auparavant ce qui veut
dire que la somme
j'attribue est distribué aux joueurs
passent de 3 millions et demi
l'édition 2016 à 6 million trois cent
mille euros l'équivalent de 7 millions
de dollars ce qui signifie que nous
aurons d'autres joueurs internationaux
qui seront attirés en dehors du fait que
ça sera le théâtre de la ryder cup mais
qui sont attirés par cette nouvelle
série mondiale qui s'appelle rolex
séries zoua série si on veut et qui
engendrera l'arrivée de deux joueurs
d'une dimension plus grande si je veux
dire mes propos j'essaie juste de les
mesurer tout simplement au mapaq
dévaluer ou dévaloriser ce qui joue
l'open de france aujourd'hui sont tous
dignes de respect mais vous avez
d'autres champions qui ne viennent pas
et qui pourrait de ce fait venir vous
avez vous avez vous pensé à des noms en
particulier les pistes oui j'ai enfin
des pistes non c'est un peu tôt mais je
pensais à jordan smith par exemple qui
pourrait avoir envie de venir mais
d'autres joueurs américains ou
asiatiques qui viendrait sur le pen de
france alors qu'ils tenaient pas c'était
déjà l'un des tournois les forcément les
plus importants d'europe salle et du
coup encore plus ici ce n'est même dans
les tops des tournois européens
oui dans depuis des tournois mondiaux
même dirige et au niveau des tournois
européens se met à nouveau plutôt en
faron lumière et ça donne du coup un
éclairage nouveau et j'espère que non
seulement les français seront sensibles
à cette nouveauté mais également tous
les habitants de
quentin en yvelines profiteront à 2 2
d'un événement maintenant à plus forte
teneur ce mondial c'est un aspect que
vous avez aussi développé pendant cette
conférence de presse vous disiez c'est
un partenariat important mais aussi
important pour pour le golf français
puisque ça va peut éventuellement
séduire de français c'est ça aussi des
français ça aussi le but c'est ouvrir le
golf à à plus de gens oui le rendent
accessibles au plus grand nombre c'est
notre souhait le plus cher depuis
longtemps on y travaille mais c'est
aussi une entreprise de démolition des
images d'epinal que nous traînons qu'ils
n'ont plus lieu d'être
le golf est un sport ouvert à tous
accessible à tous et j'espère que ce
niveau de panne de france le démontrera
ça a été long comme négociations il ya
eu des fritures un petit peu sur la
ligne ou comment comment se sont passées
les négociations oui je cacherai pas ça
a été long keith pelley le directeur du
tour européen par led 12 mois donc voyez
12 mois pour aboutir c'est c'est
beaucoup en soyons honnêtes et il y a eu
alors nous sommes nous en première ligne
depuis seulement des semaines il ya eu
beaucoup de friture sur la ligne
notamment aux au mois de décembre où
certaines choses de bêtes clairement et
clarifier écrite et discuter pour
aboutir aujourd'hui et la boue
six membres s'est fait entre le 2
janvier et aujourd'hui même si tout
était prêt les conditions générales
n'était pas encore prise
un dernier mot et dernière question sur
sur l'impact de la ryder cup est ce que
l'effet que saint quentin et que la
france accueille la ryder cup en 2018
c'est aussi jouer en faveur de ce
partenariat
indéniablement oui mais je crois que
c'est un ensemble d'éléments
et ça a été soulignée par le vice
président du sénat
son amour de la france de paris de la
cuisine de la gastronomie du vin il l'a
dit à différentes reprises il a même
souligné la france comme à payer
romantique et vous savez que les chinois
sont sensibles au romantisme chez nous
mais d'une manière pragmatique
économique le fait d'accueillir en 2018
la ryder cup donnera à schena également
un éclairage encore plus fort oui ça a
joué ne nous cachons pas merci même
janvier non merci
un potentiel super territoire de trois
millions d'habitants les départements
des hauts-de-seine et des yvelines
poursuivent leur rapprochement en vue
d'une future fusion cette semaine il
organisait une cérémonie de voeux en
commun au haras de jardy à
marnes-la-coquette les deux présidents
des assemblées départementales en ont
profité pour faire un bilan de l'année
écoulée avec notamment la création d'une
société d'économie mixte précision donc
de patrick devedjian le président du
conseil départemental du 92 c'est au
micro une nouvelle fois de nicolas quere
lovis kirillovitch assisté de camille
lambert
monsieur devedjian vous avez commencé
votre discours en disant il ya un an
c'était un pari pas forcément
politiquement correct est ce que un an
après ça l'est devenu selon vous oui je
crois que ça l'est devenu d'abord parce
que nous avons fait la démonstration par
les faits c'est à dire que la fusion est
déjà dans les faits pas tous les faits
mais un nombre important de
et et d'autre part plusieurs
départements par ailleurs nous ont fait
part de leur intérêt pour notre démarche
et envisage de faire la même chose
2010 est calé quelles sont les
perspectives pour le rapprochement entre
les deux départements ce qu'il ya des
projets qui vont être mises en place des
nouveaux rapprochements dans de nouveaux
domaines peut-être et bien pierre bédier
vous l'a dit dans son discours par
lequel il a terminé cette année nous
espérons après l'élection présidentielle
faire la fusion complète au sein même de
la majorité dans les yvelines et au sein
de votre conseil départemental il ya des
voix un peu dissonante
oui il ya des gens des élus gauche
notamment qui disent que ça va trop vite
trop fort trop loin vouloir répondez
quoi est ce que vous comprenez aussi
leurs inquiétudes
ça m'amuse ça m'amuse beaucoup parce que
le président de la république sur sa
table de nuit à dessiner les nouvelles
régions
quels bouleversements d'un seul coup le
gauche n'a rien dit le trouvez ça normal
l avaler ça d'un seul coup alors que ça
pose énormément de problèmes ça eu
aucune concertation
nous nous faisons ça progressivement
li prenant le temps la patience la
gauche est indigne et les ailes à une
indignation un peu sélective non un
autre argument de la gauche est de dire
que vous en ai pas parlé au moment des
élections départementales est ce que se
dire qu'à l'époque vous pensiez pas un
tel rapprochement
on n'a pas parlé au moment de l'élection
départementale d'abord parce que on
n'était pas en mesure d'en parler même
si ça faisait l'objet de discussions
un peu informelle entre pierre bédier et
moi nous n'en avions pas parlé avec nos
élus il fallait d'abord attendre qu'il
soit élu
et puis d'abord se concerter avec eux
donc évidemment ça n'a pas fait l'objet
de la campagne
une dernière question est ce que cette
fusion qui arrive entre le département
des yvelines et aux 100 aussi un moyen
de contrecarrer la région ile de france
on sait qu'à des tensions avec valérie
pécresse aussi le la métropole du grand
paris on sait que vous n'êtes pas
forcément les plus grands fans vous
éperviers de cette métropole du grand
paris est ce que c'est un moyen aussi de
contrecarrer ces deux entités ces deux
autres collectivités
ben je distinguerai la région de la
métropole pour la région je vois pas les
problèmes que ça pose puisque nos deux
départements sont dans le même périmètre
de la région donc il n'y a aucune
contradiction
en revanche pour la métropole on peut
considérer que ya peut-être une
difficulté en réalité la difficulté
c'est d'avoir cinq niveaux de
collectivités locales je rappelle que le
grand lyon en a que deux et en france à
paris le grand paris nous avons cinq
niveaux or si l'on doit supprimer des
niveaux il faut supprimer les niveaux
qui sont vides de contenu vite de
professionnalisme vite d'expérience ça
n'est pas le cas de la commune ce n'est
pas le cas du département qui s'il n'y
avait pas les départements en dehors des
autoroutes et des rues de nos villes
il y aurait plus de voirie en france
toute la voirie française est faite par
les départements
merci beaucoup pour vos réponses merci
patrick devedjan vous l'avez entendu
comme pierre bédier souhaite donc
accélérer la fusion de ces départements
dès les élections de 2010 est terminée
ils veulent donc débattre du projet avec
l'ensemble des élus départementaux pour
pouvoir ensuite le soumettre ce projet à
l'état alors qu'en pensent les
différents élus je vous propose tout
d'abord d'écouter jean michel fourgous
il est élu sur le canton de trappes
je pense que les rapprochements de
structures publiques comme deux grands
départements qui ont une proximité
culturelle économique géographique
bien sûr ça mérite de s'interroger vous
dire que c'est faire je peux pas vous le
dis que je peux vous le garantir mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose de
fort dans cette proposition quel est
l'avantagé selon good de rapprocher deux
départements comme ça c'est la
mutualisation c'est sais quoi d'autre
est-ce que c'est aussi l'idée de ne
peser contre eux une région qui souhaite
s'imposer toujours plus une métropole du
grand paris qui souhaite aussi joué son
rôle à l'avenir
est-ce qu'il ya aussi derrière cette
idée de rapprochement entre les deux
départements en a mais on sait que sont
les régions sont sont peu contestées on
voit bien dans le monde comment ça
s'organise
je crois que près de
50 % du pib mondial se fait dans un
petit nombre de grands territoires bon
donc les régions font partie de ces
territoires ont donc le saas est d'une
entité qui est assez admise dans le
monde entier après il y a
la métropole ça ya discussion à quoi ça
sert
après vous allez département est-ce que
les départements ont vocation à se
rassembler tous derrière la région passe
et un débat est ce que demain on va
faire un seul élus départementaux qui
vient
élue régionale saissac c c'est la grande
question maintenant les rapprochements
quand c'est des rapprochements
intelligent avec des vraies synergies
avec une bonne volonté et qui fait
vraiment baisser le niveau d'impôt le
niveau des bancs publics
oui on y va mais je pense que il faut
que et la région et le département
trouve un rythme c'est aux négociations
actuelles en mai par contre
d'autres d'autres d'autres périmètre
d'agglomération c'est vrai que c'est
insupportable aujourd'hui on peut pas on
à 57 % de dépenses publiques du pib faut
arrêter on soulignera tout même
l'opposition de certains élus du
département des yvelines pourtant du
même bord politique de philippe
brillault le maire du chesnay à
christine boutin en passant par yves
vandewalle tous les trois sièges au sein
du conseil départemental des yvelines
ils ont déjà opposé
ils se sont déjà plusieurs fois opposé à
ce projet et nous vous proposerons
procès allait prochainement sur cette
antenne un débat avec les différents
acteurs de ce dossier c'est la fin du
set 8 les invités pour ce soir n'oubliez
pas les replays sur notre site internet
excellente soirée à très bientôt
[Musique]